Donald Trump was caught lying again very
very badly very obviously and I tell you
this because I am trying to communicate
as best I can the urgent nature of
removing this man in the fall for the
betterment of all humanity including
Americans and really every country on
Earth would benefit almost every country
anyway Donald Trump said Tuesday that
soon we will be testing more than five
million people per day now that would be
great we need to be testing five million
people a day or close to it would be
fantastic and then yesterday Trump said
who said that five million no I never
said that maybe somebody said that I'll
play the videos for you you be the judge
as always take a look well we're gonna
be there very soon if you look at the
numbers it could be that we're getting
very close I mean I don't have the exact
numbers we would have had them if you
asked me the same question a little
while ago because people with these
statistics were there we're gonna be
there very soon you're confident we can
surpass five million people per day
we're going to be there soon Trump says
now that's big news we're only testing
about 200,000 people a day we were able
to go from 200,000 to 5 million it would
be fantastic we would be able to more
quickly look at opening up but that
would be 25 times more than we're doing
now so that that's really a big deal so
that was Tuesday
here's Wednesday where Donald Trump says
5 million a day I never said that where
did you get that we will very soon be
testing 5 million people well I don't
know where it came on yes I'd like to
refer to these two people because I
don't know where it came up everyone
kept saying you said there'd be five
that was a study that came out somebody
came out with the study of five million
people do I think we will I think we
won't but I never said it we're testing
millions of people we're testing more
people than anyone any country in the
world by far by double by much more than
double more than everybody else combined
with testing but somebody started
throwing around five million
I didn't say 5 million somebody said 5
million I think it might have been the
Harvard report
there was a report from Harvard and they
said five million well we will be there
but I didn't say it I mean I didn't say
it but somebody came out with a report
saying five million sounds like a lot I
never said it I don't know where it came
from somebody said it oh we will be
there but it wasn't me who said it be
very real with me I this I'm coming to
you in the audience do you think Trump
is lying here or do you think Trump's
memory is gone was Trump notified maybe
in the 24 hours the intervening 24 hours
by someone who said you know we're not
going to be testing five million a day
anytime soon it would be great if we
were but we're not going to and so Trump
decided on Wednesday I'll just lie and
say I never said it or is Donald Trump
unable to remember his Trump's mind
really turned to mayonnaise the way so
many people around Trump have claimed
has happened in the last year or 18
months I don't know the answer which is
why I'm asking you because it's not even
that Trump sort of concedes we will get
to five million a day in in the Tuesday
clip he says we'll look at another part
of it Trump says we will exceed that
soon this is earlier in the same
exchange with the reporter say US per
day by June in order to safely reopen
you unveiled a plan yesterday that will
increase testing but not by that much
why not and can you get to that venture
well we'll increase it and it'll
increase it by much more than that in
the very near future we're way ahead of
everyone on testing we're going to go
beyond that he says next day he says I
never said that no never said it maybe
the answer is it doesn't matter whether
Trump is lying or doesn't remember
because he's the same guy who said this
about 15 coronavirus cases not very long
ago we have a total of 15 cases and
again when you have 15 people and the 15
within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero that's a pretty
good job we've done we know how that
worked out
right we now have just shy of 1.1
million cases
Trump not understanding how vaccines
work at the early stages of the virus
and Donald Trump understand understating
the expected case numbers there by
ninety nine point nine nine eight
percent give him a break guys he only
understated the case numbers that we
were going to have by ninety nine point
nine nine eight percent so that's the
latest there it's sad it highlights the
urgency of removing this man and any
opportunity that I have to talk about
testing as an opportunity I'm going to
take so just indulge me for a moment
over the last week the United States has
done on average two hundred and
seventeen thousand tests per day this is
terrible
for a country of our population we need
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna do at
absolute minimum like a month ago we
should have been doing five hundred
thousand a day we're about at two twenty
that would put us on a path to do a
million tests a day and even better
would be two million tests a day even
those numbers are lower than where some
public health experts believe we need to
be and the way to the higher testing
numbers most likely is going to be an
antigen test an important element to
understand right now coronavirus tests
are PCR tests that's typically a favor
to test because of his accuracy but it
takes a lot of resources material
resources and personnel resources it's
very hard to scale PCR testing to the
numbers we need the PCR test works by
looking for evidence of the genetic
material of the virus in the body now
you have a different type of test that
can be developed called an antigen test
this is what we have for the flu right
now and the antigen test looks for what
are called viral surface proteins
antigen testing is much simpler you can
scale it way more dramatically the tough
part is developing the antigen test to
start with you need a deeper
understanding of the virus which
proteins to look for once you figure out
how to make an antigen test you can
develop many more tests 1 million a day
2 million a day would be practical
really with an antigen test and even dr.
Burks admitted a couple weeks ago
you're not going to test the country of
300 million with a PCR test which is
what we have now we need an antigen test
although dr. Burks says many things that
are not accurate she was correct about
that one of our sponsors is Cutts
clothing giving you 15% off their entire
collection of super quality men's
t-shirts at david pakman.com slash cuts
that's cu TS the solid color t-shirt is
a core component of any guy's wardrobe
certainly of mine which is all the more
reason why you should love the t-shirts
in your closet it impacts your
day-to-day life your typical poorly made
t-shirt scratches it shrinks the neck
stretches the color fades the whole
thing warps over time none of those
things happen with cuts clothing as soon
as I put one of their shirts on for the
first time I noticed the comfort I
notice the quality I noticed the look
and the fit and it's actually it's a
noticeable level of quality which would
be appropriate for something like going
on a date or going into the office if
you're watching on YouTube I am wearing
the classic Henley right now as you can
see go check out what cuts clothing has
to offer you will see and feel the
difference as soon as you put it on the
slogan is it's the only shirt worth
wearing and you will see why and you'll
get 15% off what's better than that by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS